welcome everybody i want to start today
with another republican senator who is
saying something so uncontroversial but
it becomes controversial because of how
radically authoritarian the republican
party has become but also even though
he's saying something true and
uncontroversial he's not our ally he's
not our friend he's still a radical
republican senator i know i'm being kind
of cryptic in the introduction but
there's really three issues here issue
number one is it's become controversial
to say that joe biden really won issue
number two is that former president
donald trump continues to be triggered
like a little boy anytime anybody tells
the truth about the 2020 election and
issue number three is we should not be
confused these aren't our ally
republicans they're radical republicans
who accept an uncontroversial fact if a
republican said
we need water to live we wouldn't say
they're our ally we would say no we
agree about something completely
uncontroversial and they are still
radical republicans so let's get right
into it so that you will understand what
i'm talking about
republican senator
mike round
uh he appeared
uh at rounds fl uh plural that is he
appeared on sunday with abc's george
stephanopoulos and he said in very un
uh ambiguous terms
that they lost the 2020 presidential
election this isn't news to you
it's not news to me but there haven't
been that many republicans that speak
this clearly so let's take a listen to
what mike rounds had to say
here we go
you heard martha raddatz's piece right
there how do what do you say you you
voted to certify uh the election last
year you condemned the protests as an
insurrection what do you say to all
those republicans all those veterans who
believe the election was stolen who've
bought
the falsehoods coming from former
president trump
we looked as a part of our due diligence
we looked at over 60 different
accusations made
in multiple states
while there were some irregularities
there were none of the irregularities
which would have risen to the point
where they would have changed the vote
outcome in a single state
the election was fair as fair as
we've seen
we simply did not win the election as
republicans for the presidency
and moving forward and that's the way we
want to look at this moving forward we
have to refocus once again on what it's
going to take to win the presidency
right actually trying to convince people
that it's in their best interests to
vote for you if we simply look back and
tell our people don't vote because you
know there's cheating going on
then we're going to put ourselves in a
huge disadvantage so moving forward
let's focus on what it takes to win
those elections we can do that but we
have to let people know that they can
they can believe and they can have
confidence that those elections are fair
and uh and and and that is in every
single state that we looked at so this
is not controversial this is a senator
simply saying we lost
we lost that that's all that happened
there were not more irregularities than
there typically are
they didn't affect results in even a
single state we lost and we've got to
figure out how to win so number one is
that's controversial among many
republicans at this point in time
roughly half of whom still believe the
election wasn't really won by joe biden
this gets us to donald trump's response
this uncontroversial statement from a
republican which it being controversial
is part of the story
triggers the former president to no end
within
a few hours of this happening very early
yesterday after this statement came out
on sunday donald trump puts out a
statement
quote senator
he puts it in quotes senator mike rounds
of the great state of south dakota just
went woke
on the capital f fraudulent presidential
election of 2020. no he didn't
woke
it he just said hey we they got more
votes and therefore they won
he made a statement this weekend on abc
fake news that despite massive evidence
to the contrary including much of it
pouring in from wisconsin georgia
arizona michigan pennsylvania and other
states there's no evidence pouring in
guys he found the election to be okay
just fine is he crazy or just stupid the
numbers are conclusive and the
fraudulent and irregular votes are
massive that's untrue the only reason he
did this is because he got my
endorsement easily and got my
endorsement and easily won his state in
2020. so now he thinks he has time and
those are the only ones the weak who
will break away even though his election
will not be coming up with for five
years i will never endorse this jerk
again
it's rhinos like this remember rhino
means republican in name only
it's a term they use to mean
they have an r next to their name but
they're not really a republican there's
a litmus test now for trump if you
believe he really lost you're not really
a republican trump writing it's rhinos
like this that are allowing the
democrats to destroy our nation and then
he goes on with the normal stuff the
radical left democrats and rhinos like
senator mike rounds don't make it easy
for our country to succeed he's a weak
and ineffective leader and i hereby
firmly pledge that he will never receive
my endorsement again
so second part of the story is
this is a former president an adult by
all by all technical measures
who
is relegated to sandbox playground
insults anytime somebody says something
that's uncomfortable uncontroversial now
the third part and this is the really
important part is these people are not
our friends these people are not allies
liz cheney adam kinzinger they recognize
joe biden really won great but you
shouldn't get a pat on the back for that
that's just reality it's like
recognizing the sun rises and sets you
know um
but they voted with trump almost
exclusively cheney and kinzinger
and similarly mike rounds is a radical
republican he doesn't get any praise
from us
we note that it's wild that him saying
biden won
is out of step with the republican party
but this guy is no friend of ours he was
one of the 22 senators who signed a
letter telling trump to pull out of the
paris climate agreement
he supported remember scott pruitt from
the epa who was caught spending insane
amounts of money on luxury travel for
his fam like a completely beyond the
pale mike rounds stood by scott pruitt
rounds opposed the first step act which
was one of the few okay things that
donald trump actually did as president
he has voted to repeal the affordable
care act multiple times
he um abstained from even voting on the
creation of the panel to investigate
what happened on january 6th mike rounds
is a radical we don't like mike round so
we have to remember that when we say wow
this guy's willing to accept an
incontrovertible truth we don't see him
as a friend of the left because he's not
he's still a radical
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which just makes it really easy for me
to get the vitamins and minerals that i
want every day i don't always have time
to get exactly what i want from the
foods i'm eating but athletic greens
ag-1 is a drink mix that gives you
everything you need all at once it's
just one scoop and you get 75 high
quality vitamins and minerals as well as
probiotics so it supports gut health it
is one of the great sort of add-ons to
having proper balanced nutrition
athletic greens ag-1 has become a
regular part of my day i'll put it in a
smoothie it tastes great sometimes i'll
just drink it by itself and it's been a
really great and convenient way to get
everything i would get from a
multivitamin and minerals and probiotics
that i might otherwise take separately
athletic greens is giving my audience a
free one-year supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com
pacman the link is down below